we have to be the party of parents the
one thing that is Manifest today
throughout this country is that school
choice and parental involvement is now
more important than it's ever been
before I think it is 67 percent of
Democrats 68 of The Independents 70
percent of African-Americans 74 of
Hispanics 80 of dual income Working
Families all support some form of school
choice after looking at the devastating
learning loss and the precipitous drop
in scores
we have to lead for parents
what do you make of the the general
thing that's happening across the
country which is that the states really
do seem to be going in very different
directions I mean I feel like I live in
a different country honestly I don't
mean that to be California to Florida
you move from almost a different country
it seems like I mean literally at you
know 3 000 miles but truly it feels like
a different country obviously if you
live in South Carolina that's going to
feel very different than living in New
York covet exacerbate a lot of that are
you generally okay with that concept
well listen I think we've had we've had
very unique and interesting times in in
American history where the states felt a
tension that at some times was not
healthy and that we overcame that I I do
think we're in another one of those
moments where we're seeing the states
divide amongst themselves naturally I
mean the good news is when you can work
and live where you want to you move from
California
to Florida you know or you should have
stopped by the way in South Carolina and
called it home we say those folks who
moved from like New Jersey to Cal to
Florida and then they come back to South
Carolina that's what typically happens
over time we call those folks halfbacks
as they went all the way down they went
all the way down they came halfway back
so Jackie Haley did a number on me too
it was on the list it was on the list I
have family in Florida and that really
was like the they can move up to South
Carolina too no problem we have room for
for your family as well we like red
voting cards I have a newly registered
Republican for the first time in my life
I had 46 years I love it so all right so
let's do a little bit of uh projecting
going forward here obviously these
midterms are coming you know most
conventional thinking is there's going
to be some kind of Red Wave the
incumbent party never does that well in
the midterms uh what do you think is
going to happen what do you want to
happen
well if I had my brothers we would win
the Senate with about two or three seats
to spare uh we would have the house with
about when I came into the house in 2010
I think we had 63 new seats in the house
uh that was a banner year without any
question if I had it my way we'd have
that kind of a red tsunami what I think
is going to happen I think we will
control the house at the end of this
election and there is a decent chance
that we can control the Senate as well
we need to execute on the field the the
game is coming down to the last two
minutes the score is going to be close
to tie tied and I want to make sure that
when you give the ball as a quarterback
if you turn and you give your ball to
your running back I'm I'm hoping that
Herschel will be jumping over the the
the goal line in the air with the ball
secured no fumbles and winds back
Georgia and I'm very confident that Ted
Bud will will do a 4.5 out and score on
his two two minute drills out there and
I'm hoping that Dr Oz will be the coach
on the sideline and drawing up the play
and and we'll execute as he was the
Harvard quarterback so maybe he'll
scramble to the left and and hit hit the
receiver for a three-yard score and then
JD Vance I know he's a good author so
I'm not going to play football but he
can kick the extra point heck fire and
win that race I got to tell you I'm more
of a basketball guy but the references
are all working I'm following good good
I'm about done because I started with
Herschel I know nothing about basketball
but maybe we can just get JD advanced in
the dunk the ball uh after someone else
spikes it I'm sure you don't Spike the
basketball you don't expect a basketball
uh all right so but okay so if that
happens let's say you get something
close to what you want even if it's even
if it's not that that you know three
Senators over Etc but you get some of
that exactly what do you think changes
here what do you think honestly changes
well the first thing that should change
if we control both houses is that we
start oversight we an oversight
objective to rein In This Very
unwieldy group of Democrats running this
country in the abiding Administration
they need oversight like a
three-year-old needs a parent to say
don't do this I mean literally we need
to bring the oversight hammer down
number two we have to be the party of
parents the one thing that is Manifest
today throughout this country is that
school choice and parental involvement
is now more important than it's ever
been before I think it is 67 percent of
Democrats 68 percent of The Independents
70 percent of African-Americans 74 of
Hispanics 80 percent of dual income
Working Families all support some form
of school choice after looking at the
devastating learning loss and the
precipitous drop in scores
we have to lead for parents that's the
second thing we should do and the third
thing we have to do uh in my opinion is
to con control our Southern border and
build a physical impediment it is a
national security risk it is a fentanyl
and Drug risk and it is two and a half
million illegal Crossing in the illegal
immigration risk and finally what is
obvious to all of us
if you just turn the spending off I
believe inflation comes down in a real
and manifest way if you start talking
about tax policy that makes sense and
and predictability in the regulatory
State people with certainty and
predictability they go back to creating
jobs they go back to making sure that
they're making long-term Investments
that helps to Spur the economic engines
in a way that attracts jobs back to
America and high-tech manufacturing and
the stem future becomes ours I know that
no Senator wants to be asked this much
less on their birthday but uh I mean the
national Ambitions will like it's it
seems like you fit in there man I mean
it just seems like the message the tone
as I said the age like it seems it seems
right to me
you know uh Dave I'll tell you my
national ambition is to travel this
country for the next seven weeks and my
home state in order to win the
majorities in the house and the Senate I
am a guy that I figured out one thing
several years ago applying for jobs is
the worst way to get a job the best way
to get a job is to do that job like no
one's ever done it before and that's one
of the reasons why in the last three
weeks or so I've been to Florence and
Myrtle Beach and Columbia and Charleston
and Anderson South Carolina as well as
Rock Hill and I'll be in Greenville and
Spartanburg and Columbia again in the
next couple weeks but I'm also in Iowa
Nebraska
Wisconsin Michigan Tennessee Florida
Georgia and North Carolina in the last
just few weeks and I'll do more of the
same in the next few weeks because I
believe that the most important
thing I can do with my time and my good
health is to invest it in the future of
America because one day there will be
kids like yours running this country and
we need to make sure they start off
looking at the city on the hill that
doesn't happen on accident I think for
the last few years we thought is that is
that the sort of scariest part of what's
going on that we seemingly have given up
just what that flag right behind you
represents just almost like that like we
just don't I know we do and the people
watching this but so much of the ethos
of America seems to have given up on
that dream and that aspirational message
you know there's there's something about
and I don't mean this to be negative and
I don't mean this to be insulting I just
mean it to be real this concept of being
a global citizen where everything is all
merged together is really unhealthy for
the United States of America the thing
that has always been a part of American
exceptionalism is not standing apart
only it's standing above it's leading
the world not being a part of it I want
to help other countries succeed beyond
their wildest imagination but that
starts by having America succeeding
beyond our wildest imagination we are
the standard when the standard becomes
average the world becomes subpar if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
fight of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell